[Music]
before i i was a professional uh and i
didn't have money i was driving down to
this is a terrible beginning i like it
so far you do yeah uh well anyway i
drove to key west um i had always been
fascinated with florida we've talked
about that on the show and uh but it was
my first time driving to key west and it
was on a holiday was on either like
halloween or same past some big day
where all of the hotels had been booked
and certainly anything in my price range
so i found one thing
um i think it was probably like 50
which for me was a lot of money at the
time and
i i
underestimated how long it would take me
to get there um i got there late like
around midnight or one right when
all the revelers were in you know full
swing and people were out on the streets
and was but i was exhausted so i just
went right to the hotel and um
i realized that it was the catch was the
reason was so cheap is because it was a
shared bathroom situation
yeah and which of course you're not good
for you no i got i got squirrely about
that and um
panicked a little bit and i asked the
proprietor of the hotel if i could
change my mind and uh he kindly gave me
my money back but then i had no place to
stay so i had to get back in the car and
drive back up that beautiful tribe at
like one in the morning
to find something within my price range
you are one of the poo shyest people
i've ever met yeah i blame my mother for
it um
but uh that's that's for a different
episode okay we can sort that out when
we have like a psychiatrist on or our
mother on life could be a dream
life could be a dream
you're listening to life for short i am
your uh pusha hi host justin long life
could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
and with me as always is
my poo confident brother and co-host
christian i remember once in college i
was sharing i had to share a bathroom
i heard the guy in the other dorm come
into the bathroom which he was able to
do because it was he had every right to
it and
i was pooping
and just to let him know i was in there
i started whistling to myself just so
like i've done that just to give him a
heads up
i thought it'd be more subtle just a
whistle and i've done that on doors that
don't lock yes i'll go
and without missing a beat he just uh he
just goes
oh poo whistle oh like it was a thing
it's a thing like he knew about oh
that's funny
i love that i love that concept
yeah yeah that's funny i i don't know
where my thing comes from really but i
had to pee really badly once in front of
um we were some with some family friends
that we've talked about this before i
forget how old i was i was probably in
like first or sec second grade i think
and
i kind of remember not wanting to ask
them
i don't know i must have had shame about
it so i just started peeing against a
tree
in the yard you don't remember this no i
peed in the yard and everybody was like
uh what are you doing what um
and our parents were like mortified
and i remem and i remember damian being
like remember our older brother being
like
you should not have done that it was
well
i i remember feeling really like a lot
of shame from that well why are we
talking about um
your poo shyness um well because on uh
bring us back bring us back all right
well that trip that i was taking to key
west which is an island was uh a bit of
a fantasy it was a it was the first time
i had been on the road really on like a
i'm by myself on a long car ride and and
florida to me had always been very
exotic and so there was something
there it was like a fantasy island that
oh i see what you're doing that's a
stretch but it turned out to be uh not a
fantasy but it but at the time the
opposite of a fantasy yeah a nightmare
not being able to poo i know that's a
nightmare island yeah
my
and um but our guest today is uh on a
show called fantasy island a new a
remake of fantasy yeah she's not not in
the original no no the remake is out now
and uh um it's a it's a really fun show
and uh on fox on fox yeah um and she
plays the main character
she plays the niece right of from the
original ricardo montebon's characters
niece and her name is
the character or no no i was gonna i'm
setting myself up for the introduction
oh go for it her name is
rosalind sanchez star of rush hour two
she was on without a trace devious maids
a lot of hit tv shows a lot of shows
she's no stranger to tv fans we didn't
know her uh we knew her as an actress
but of course this is the first time i
got to talk to her you never met her
nope she is
carrying the torch of fantasy island now
she's the star of it and um she's a
great actress our friend togo friend we
talk about him a lot on the show uh i
think he worked with her on csi miami
let's get into it let's hear from her
all right so yeah enough enough with us
already um here she is this is my first
my introduction and maybe yours um
unless you watch tv then you already
know her uh here she is rosalind sanchez
[Music]
hi
how are you guys hi i amanda you see me
i'm like i'm freaking out because i'm so
bad at this technology [ __ ] so am i good
you're like this you're you're this way
okay
better do you see me now better oh my
goodness am i good no thanks rosalind
that's thank you rosalind this is so
superficial but how long does it take to
grow hair that length oh my goodness you
know i never cut my hair so i have no
idea but probably many many years
and the older you get
this lower the process so that's why i
don't like cutting my freaking hair
oh i didn't know that that hair ceases
to grow as rapidly
i i mean that's been my experience i'm
not 100 maybe i made that up but i
believe that the older you get then the
longer it's going to take the hair
doesn't react as fast to cutting your
ends you know it doesn't grow as fast i
think
that's what not to be
not to get started off on a morbid no
but i i heard the thing that always used
to freak me out was that hair continues
to grow after death
no
yes i think so hair and nails
no is that true we should fact check it
but i'm pretty sure so i always think
when i cut my nails i think about it
sometimes like well you know i'm doing
all this maintenance now but one day
it'll just be
yeah they're all the i know that's gonna
hunt me the entire day i wanna i'm gonna
look that up as soon as we're done here
i'm gonna look that up because i'll be
very interesting i don't see you anymore
justine where are you oh start my video
somebody said start my video oh there we
go there you go there you go um i you
know it was so flattering to hear the
alarm in your voice when i disappeared
for a second it really concerned me i
was like no i need to i need to see his
face
where'd he go
rosalie where where are you exactly yes
it's a beautiful backdrop
thank you you know what we created this
this is my husband's condo
this is not my home and we do we did the
we have a podcast as well that we used
to go to i heart and because of kovid
now we do it out of our house and we
were basically inside uh our closet
um to be able to find some peace and
quiet because we have the kids and it's
been a bit it was a bit of a nightmare
so
down the street he has um we were pretty
much neighbors and we didn't know each
other 15 years ago before we got married
no kidding and yes isn't it crazy so his
mom lives here it's three bedrooms it's
a massive place and the office we're
like you know we might as well just turn
this little office into a little studio
thingy and this is what we're doing the
podcast and it's still a work in
progress we're still like dealing with
it but this is where i'm in los angeles
and my husband's hundo
oh wow and ruslan what is the um
what you said you didn't know each other
but you happened to live nearby did you
meet in the neighborhood then or did you
just discover that after getting to know
each other after you know we met at some
hollywood some sony it was like a
an event you know very typical way of
meeting to actors meeting meeting at an
event so that's what we made and then we
started i know nothing about that
exactly and then he said where do you
live i'm going to the city oh my god i
miss you city as well now where here oh
okay so we realized we are literally we
were literally two minutes away those
are always funny moments when you're
getting to know somebody we're like oh
where do you live you don't want to say
specifically of course but that's you
know but but then but then the closer
when you start whittling down wait i
live in that area where exactly and that
you whittle it down to that
approximation is really it was very
convenient it was very practical because
it was oh my god you know this kid lives
so close so it was it was perfect that
was probably the only thing that really
uh
attracted you to the only thing you know
i was in my 30s i was like i want to
make this very very easy and practical
he's a neighbor okay let's do it
yeah yeah that's what you get to know
like those are the important things the
convenience
it's really attractive
um what is he so is he an actor as well
ruslan he's an actor yeah he's an actor
he does a tv show for abc called the
rookie with nathan feeling oh yeah
yeah yeah he's fantastic so eric does uh
the show it's been uh picked up for a
fourth season so he's been you know how
difficult it is to have a show last
uh more than one season let alone four
you know so they're doing really well
sorry rosalind eric what's this
winter i i know eric uh we worked
together we did i think we did a movie
called comet did he make a movie called
comet oh wait maybe not maybe with who
first of all with like tell me who else
is in the movie emmy rossum is in it as
well and under the under the the
director sam ishmael sam her her now
husband sam yeah he did that yes that's
eric yes
rosario dawson no
uh no no it was emmy ross no but there
was another one that he did so yeah but
i i do believe it's that one because he
knows her husband that directed it and
that's how they met so he's yeah so
that's him that's eric you're absolutely
oh isn't that funny
um and it's slightly
yeah i wonder how he feels about you not
having seen that movie
i wonder if that would bother him
eric winter yes he played josh
i was doing something awful and this is
i shouldn't even say it you know i
shouldn't even say it because i just did
an interview with ktla talking about
being supportive
now you have to say it
nobody listens
listen to me this freaking i've never
seen the rookie i did i did a guest star
i know the show very well because i know
the story lines because he tells me and
i love all the all the cast members and
they're like a family and i love the
show but i really haven't seen the show
isn't that isn't that awful i don't know
no you know what it probably sounds
that's the nice thing about podcasts is
because it records the nuances of
something like that but out of context
if that were a sound bite that might
sound bad yes if it was just i don't
watch your show but i know exactly what
you mean especially if you're living
with
you know you know everyone you're
friendly with everyone and it's also an
hour-long show it's it's you already
know what's happening you live with this
person he probably doesn't want to
you know be around it when he comes home
to you i that does not seem strange to
me at all
and my apologies i don't want because i
know the show is huge and people love it
and i love it i love it because he loves
it he's so happy there and i did a guest
her and he was fabulous uh well yeah
he's really good but he's really good
and he's done amazing listen he is
playing against type they didn't even
want to see him for the role because
this guy started as such like a tool you
know what i mean he was like morbid leo
he's playing like a morbidly obese
shut-in no not that but
okay
all right
it's not it's not what people think when
they think about eric winter so he
fought for this
and he tested and he got it and he's
been able to do a wonderful job people
love his character so my apologies for
the rookie fans i i am a supportive one
i am very happy for him
but i haven't seen that and it's
interesting because every time i said
you have to watch my show and yeah i
want you to watch the episode he said
why should i do that you don't watch my
show and go hang out okay
yeah there you go it's a tit for tat
situation exactly uh well eric was
he played a character who was very um
really douchey the character has to be
overtly douchey because my character
does tries to steal his girlfriend which
which isn't an inherently
shitty thing to do
and so in order to justify it they
needed him to be extra douchey you know
like extra shitty to her and and um it
struck me that he was he was so nice
off camera and and so convincingly
douchey in the scene so i i know that he
is a good actor and he is a friendly guy
but he is a very sweet guy and i call
him mr congeniality because eric gets
along with he gets along with any
anybody he's just he's just a a good
good human being oh well i'm happy you
ended up with him and you have two uh
young children and um what do they do
they watch the rookie what do they think
of what you do do they watch fantasy
island um you know sabella i did a
little screening for the episode last
week with some friends and i took her
and
she's not incredibly interested you know
she's she's seeing it because mom is in
your work specifically
exactly exactly yeah i think the little
one yeah i know the little one is only
three so he doesn't really know what's
going on um sabella is nine he she grew
up going to set so she's very much aware
but it's not something that
to be honest with you i don't think she
cares that much she's like mom and dad
they get recognized when we go out and
they might ask for a picture and they to
them isabella is kind of like oh okay
which is
which is nice because it means she
probably won't develop any sort of like
complex about fame and and
you know she won't value it in the way
that i think a lot of people value it in
an unhealthy way uh yes i think so nice
yeah i think so wow
what what how different is her
upbringing rosalind than yours was
you're the youngest of four you it's
incredible we have three older brothers
um yeah what was it what was that
dynamic like for you um compared to how
your own daughter's growing up
different life different universe to be
honest with you
in puerto rico
uh my parents were not in the business
at all i'm the only one in my family
that um
is in the entertainment business i grew
up in a very middle-class uh
island girl my life was uh wow going
into
the beach and going to school in ballet
like i
my life it sounds idyllic
yeah yes yes very much you know i
remember that i was like uh the
neighborhood um
there were like it was like five or six
of us after school after ballet i would
come home and i would play with my girls
all over the street it was a very normal
normal childhood sebela my daughter
it's la i'm up in the hills
i barely know my neighbors she doesn't
know what it is to have a neighbor and
just go and play a condition community
she doesn't honestly she doesn't she
doesn't have that sense of community
um we try to do our best we have good
friends you know they have kids and we
do play dates but it's a it's a it's a
different life moment that are both
actors she's been traveling the world
since she was born it's very different
there's a part of me that loves it you
know that she has this incredibly
creative
unique different upbringing but there's
also part of me that goes
i wish you she would know what it means
to have community and to have
girlfriends and neighbors you know and
just play with mud and dirt and just run
around get your hands dirty yeah totally
yes i know i
yeah i was talking to um yeah i i know
i've been thinking about that lately i'd
love to have kids one day and um
i grew up in a very
i don't know how similar to you but it
was that we were always playing we were
always outside uh in the in the woods
like getting our just getting dirty and
using our imaginations and together
there are a lot of kids i remember just
running around with at summers were just
like we were out all day we were like
feral kids
yeah exactly pretty much you know you're
absolutely right and it was there was
just more freedom there was more
innocence kids nowadays
they grow so fast you know it's pretty
bad it's it's pretty scary you know as a
parent it
it's scary i'm not gonna lie to you you
go it's such a big responsibility you
know i bet i bet well because you don't
think about the dane you know we've only
thought about the benefits i have anyway
of having like the world at our
fingertips with these phones but
you know the flip side of that is like
kids have the world at their fingertips
and the world is you know with all of it
all of its um inconsistencies and and
and all of its
ugliness really uh so there's the
ugliness
yeah
yeah
no not that i want to talk about covet
but can you imagine you're nine years
old eight years old your entire third
grade
you have to basically be homeschooled
because there's a virus
completely comprehend and to be able to
navigate um those waters are it's crazy
and all kinds of mental all the mental
issues develop that have been developed
these kids are it's a different
well oh my god
i never considered that that there is
during these formative years a very
formative time in their lives forget
that they're home and all that and
everything's kind of thrown off but the
idea that adults who at that age to me
were infallible you know which is
probably not a healthy way to look at
adults but they were they were like i
looked up to adults adults don't know
they don't have an answer for this thing
and so just that gent that reality
living as a kid living with that reality
what i wonder what that's going to do to
the collective psyche that's a really
good point i think it's going gonna be
an issue and i think we're gonna see uh
later on you know
we're going to it's gonna be manifested
how damaging yeah it was uh for these
kids and for a lot of adults for this
for for these children that and that in
between like they're still kids but
they're about to be teenagers but
they're still right
and they had to live through years of
wearing a mask and which is needed and
i'm all for it but it's it's really
insane like i went to the store
yesterday with my kid with dylan he was
three years old he's three years old
and i don't know what happened usually
when we go out he has a little mask and
this time we we i didn't even notice
that he didn't have a mask when we went
to the store we got back to the car i'm
putting on his car seat and i'm you know
like like
put in the car seat and i go dylan your
mask and he's like what i'm going you
must and i panicked i had to check
myself going i panicked i'm going to
where's your mouth where's your mouth
what's your freaking mess he's like and
he's three years old and he's like uh
you're here how come you didn't put it
on and after i had to go rush stop it
because you gotta freaking you don't
wanna be freaking out this kid he's only
three years old and it's not that big of
a deal he's fine it's like he's
underwater and you forgot his oxygen
things i know i know yeah i mean like
like stop cripping you know and i don't
wanna damage that little mind you know
uh well that's the thing i also heard
this recently and here i am like
parents splaining like a childless
person parents blaming but i found this
really fascinating uh i thought it was
interesting my friend said um that kids
absorb uh feelings that they absorb the
feelings around them and that was a
really striking
idea to me that um
that like in this case dylan is
absorbing not necessarily the fact that
he forgot his math but your panic your
fear and um that must be that must be
hard to to be so aware of and and to be
conscientious of you know i am i am and
this is just very personal but i don't
even know because i don't want to bring
the show like down with all this scary
stuff but i am severely closer i'm
severely claustrophobic right
like like like really bad i hate like
elevators i i ninety percent
jesus doing the show in your closet must
have been tough
but it's home it's home
and and i have a big closet
yeah okay
well yeah elevators must really trip you
out i hate it
my kids um are growing up with a mom
that when we go somewhere then there's
an elevator i'm always i'm always asking
for the stairs i don't mind going 20 20
stairs because i don't want to take the
elevator you know oh my god i fly i
travel like crazy i have to medicate
myself because i don't want to have a
panic attack and they have heard the
word
panic attack several times because i'm
going oh my god i'm too hot and i get
very hot and i get like it's it's it's a
really crazy uh life when you're
claustrophobic right
so you're really like it's so it's quite
severe then
it's quite severe it's quite severe and
and isabella when like two years ago i
don't know what happened i don't know
where we were that
she goes like oh oh i think i'm having a
panic attack
she doesn't even know at two seven i'm
going i'm uh mom i'm having a panic
attack i
died because i was like ross what have
you done to this little girl like the
last thing i want is to be able to pass
that on
yes like you're talking about because
you want your kids to be better than you
right a hundred percent yeah
the whole thing about being a parent is
you want to elevate that soul to be
100 times what you were you know what i
mean so so they have a different
experience in life and and by them
feeling energy recognizing feelings you
know like letting letting that affect
them i was like i need to
somehow
find the wisdom the courage the strength
to check myself and not use that
language in front of them and even if
i'm having a panic attack i don't know
what the heck i'm gonna have to do that
they don't see it you know so because i
will it'll be so sad for me if
i pass that along to my children that
then one day they're severely
claustrophobic because they saw mama
totally
you know rosalind i i i that makes sense
and i really appreciate your honesty
about it um
while i'm i i have something that you
might be interested in that might be of
some value to you yesterday on the show
i was talking to dan harris who is uh
who was a really great uh correspondent
journalist but he now has um he's
devoting all his time to this meditation
app called 10
it's called the 10 hat the idea is that
you can be 10 happier with these simple
meditation techniques and and uh his
book is great too it's it's a really fun
read but it's um he details in it this
panic attack that he had on national tv
he it was
yeah beamed out to millions of people
and um
it was a full-blown panic attack that's
what kind of led him to meditation but
uh
i i i have you tried anything like that
meditating because i i found it to be
tremendously useful in my life because
i'm wired in a similar way
you know what
meditation
is so just it's so difficult for me and
i have tried
and i follow mind valley i believe is
the app that i love and i follow a lot
of meditation apps and i get like what i
call madonna fiery like i get so into it
and i'm like i'm gonna devote like at
least 10 minutes of my life and i get
the fever and then i do it for two weeks
and i'm very disciplined about it
and then i kind of like oh i'm too busy
oh i'll do it a little later i haven't
been able to i don't know if it's my
mind is way too active i don't know if
i'm like always like maybe
yeah or maybe you didn't see the
benefits uh of the one you were doing
um
and listen because of my claustrophobia
i've been to therapy psychologists
regression yeah i'm sure uh past lives
uh freaking psychics
trying to identify what what's yes the
source and yeah and the source and it's
been very difficult to do
some people think that because i grew up
i was the youngest one i'm the only girl
my youngest brother that is six years
older than me georgie which love in my
heart but when we when i was born he was
like the little king he was the youngest
one
then
the girl came in and he had a hard time
for years
yes exactly accepting that he has a
little a little sister that is getting
all the attention and i used to because
i grew up with men
i was very much a tomboy i loved like
wrestling and boxing and i was all
constantly trying to to hit them and
always playing very rough
and and georgie i mean god bless he's
going to die he uses this georgie will
grab a pillow
like he'll be like doing doing homework
and i would just run by boom and hit him
and start running just just bothering
him and he'll grab a pillow grab a
pillow and put it on top of me and until
i was almost about to pass out and he
would just let go
that's the only thing yeah so that's the
only thing it wasn't because of this
like i will get panic attacks because
i'll be like
you know what i mean like can't breathe
but i don't know if it's that i don't
know i don't know what it is i mean this
is probably not the forum to diagnose it
uh nor am i
in any way equipped to help you with it
but that sounds like a compelling factor
for sure maybe maybe a little bit of
that my mom also has it she's a little
bit but i think i got it even yeah my
mom is yeah
as well
my and again i don't want to blame oh my
mom's going to love this but she's
passed on a lot of her neurosis uh to me
and those are things that and not to
oversell meditation but any kind of any
time just the awareness of those things
i think i found to be very useful you
know so when they crop up and like like
when you had that um episode with dylan
you know just just to be aware of the
behavior and um i think that's that's a
huge uh part of it part of
growth and and you know learning
can i ask you something how many like
how how long do you do you do it every
single day yeah well i'm supposed to uh
i'm i'm like you and i'm not good at
consistency but uh i've been quite
consistent with this um only because
like i said i've
i've seen such
huge benefits in my life it's it's what
benefits well i'm i'm able to process it
triggers a lot more easily i'm i'm i'm
less reactive than i had been
um to any kind of
adversity in my life adversity i mean
like i use that term loosely it's all
relatively like if i get you know if i
get triggered by whatever anything my
mother uh in being in traffic uh any
kind of disappointment or
anxiety something if i'm late for
something like this you know okay uh
it's it's reconnecting to the breath
it's simple things it's it's uh being
mindful of
those things as they happen that's the
whole ethos it's like it's you don't
deny the thing you don't push it away
and try to cover it up you sit with it
and you
process it and you allow yourself to
feel it and i i
i don't know i've just i've been more
present as an actor i think frankly
um it's allowed me to be more present to
people to conversation you know
um
i just love it uh and the one i use
again is like and i they don't pay me
this is not i've just found such benefit
in it it's it's just called it's called
ten percent uh and the book is ten
percent happier um thank you thank you
they should pay you know thank you for
letting me know i'm gonna check it out
because i recognize today i should i'm
gonna check it out for sure so thank you
for that um yeah i need to i need to do
something um yeah yes you do we all do
[Music]
do do
[Music]
this holiday season maybe you want to
give a gift to your loved ones that make
them feel special and unique just like
you know the relationship you share
that's why story worth might be for you
it's an online service that helps you
and your loved ones preserve precious
memories and stories for years to come
it is a it's a thoughtful and meaningful
if you like those things gift that
connects that connects you to those who
matter most every week story worth
emails your relative or friend a
thought-provoking question of your
choice from their vast pool of possible
options each unique prompt asks
questions you've never thought to ask
like what's the bravest thing you've
ever done in your life or that's a good
question if you could see the future
what would you want to find out so after
one year story worth will compile all of
your loved ones stories including photos
into a beautiful keepsake book that
you'll be able to share and revisit for
generations to come reading the weekly
stories helps you connect with loved
ones no matter how near or far apart you
are with story worth i'm giving those i
love most a thoughtful personal gift
from the heart and preserving their
memories and stories for years to come
go to storyworth.com
long and save ten dollars on your first
purchase that's
storyworth.com long to save ten dollars
on your first purchase
are you having trouble sleeping i was
not anymore right because of what plus
cbd i've been using these plus cbd sleep
gummies daily and i've been getting such
great rest and i've been waking up
feeling focused and refreshed yeah me
too there's no feeling of like
grogginess or like haziness the next
morning which you know i've taken over
the counter stuff and occasionally i'll
if i really need to sleep you know if
i'm jet lagged or whatever i'll take
something more heavy duty but um these i
haven't needed anything else these are
all natural formulated by a team of
medical experts and doctors plus cbd
sleep gummies taste great they really do
watermelon peach i've had and are made
with award-winning cbd combined with
melatonin magnolia bark and lemon balm
calm gummies are nice during the day if
you're feeling a little overwhelmed if
you want to calm down a little bit the
calm gummies are great sleep gummies are
great at night you just need a little
positive push during the day and if you
want a fun combination the reserve
collection mummies which have 25
milligrams of cbd and 2.5 milligrams of
thc
that's what we had last night yeah those
are the best they really do
and it's it's a small for me at least
it's a it's a low enough
amount of thc though that i feel
comfortable and fun and like upbeat and
happy
without getting too weird no yeah it's
it's just enough it's just enough it's
just the right amount yes a little a
little something something sleep better
tonight by visiting plus cbd oil dot com
and enter promo code long for 40 off
your order that's code long at plus cbd
oil dot com for forty percent off
hello hello
[Music]
do your kids have harbor any uh
ambitions to perform they see they're
both their parents for performers and um
you say they're kind of like you know
desensitized to it but do they do they
have that in them are they like
little rascals uh no i think dylan the
little one
he's only three so who knows you know
but i i don't
i don't think so very shy doesn't mean
that it's gonna stay like that because a
lot of kids are very shy when they're
tiny and then they grow to be handfuls
and they have they're great speakers you
know but as of now right
yeah he's more observant he's very shy
sabella it's uh she's a little bit of a
handful sabella we
she was dancing by the time she was
three and then she was playing piano
and then we have her doing yara which is
this big performing arts for kids and
she was liking it but um is more of an
athlete so bella has turned out to be a
fabulous tennis player
um
she's doing tournaments uh now um just
had one this weekend we became second
plane against a girl that is turning 13
even though she's nine
uh whoa so we're
embarrassing for the 13 year old
oh my god you know what but maybe the
girl was taking it easy you know i i
don't know
it's so much bigger than her we're like
this is going to be a massacre this is
like like like ridiculous but of course
but what sandy did fantastic and she's
more and more so we're trying to it's
interesting you know because we at some
point maybe before covid
she's been playing tennis since she was
three and a half and she was showing uh
ability you know i don't even know how
to say she's a baby but a lot of people
be like oh this girl is so athletic and
she she's great so we bought into it and
as parents you know like how cool it is
to be the the parent of an athlete you
know so yeah i bet we oh my god we
bought into this whole thing and we were
really pushing her and pressing her like
tennis tennis like everything was
everything was tense um almost like but
was she she was into it did you did you
sense that she enjoyed it can i tell you
something i don't know i think she was i
think she was until we became so all
about it
oh that
that i don't know she felt pressure
pressure so they were going to the past
and she she was like i don't want to go
to there what do you mean
but you're a tennis star you guys turn
into like the williams phoenix and
serena's parents yeah
yeah that's right to the point that this
girl was like if you if you i don't want
to go on the going you know then coving
happened so everything changed and we
built so we don't have a tennis court at
the house so my husband built it like a
tennis like like a hidden wall it was
like we were like tennis oh my god like
lunatics and then we realized what are
we doing but maybe she doesn't what a
freaking no that is you know so let's
say yeah
so then we kind of like had to like we
went to therapy we have a husband going
are we creating a monster is this girl
are we affecting her mental health
because we want it so badly for her but
she needs to want it as bad you know of
course of course i mean is that how your
parents were with you and acting i mean
like is there any spillover in terms of
like how you were parented or or were
you just more independent and yeah no my
mom was a stage mom not i don't want to
say that i don't want it to come across
back but my mom not pejorative yeah at
four i was dancing but i had six i was
playing piano by nine i was doing
commercials she was submitting me for
commercials uh pageants and i was miss
puerto rico you know i mean like my mom
was very much living in her life my mom
is an incredible she's a school teacher
she's retired she's in her 80s but my
mom can imitate anybody to a t
it's all i mean the voice their voice is
everything voice behavior my mom is
she's so funny and i think my mom was
probably like a frustrated performer so
she was she was living her life through
totally but i don't want to say that it
was in a way
it wasn't bad because thank god i loved
it you know it wasn't like yeah i'm
going to ballet but i don't like it mom
i don't want to do this i don't want to
do this i actually love you yeah you
recognize that it might be potentially
tricky that that dynamic yeah the
dynamic was tricky my mom was very
strict in terms of like
it was like tough love you know it was
tough love yeah in terms of like this is
what you're doing you didn't point your
toes this time around what the heck is
going do you think you're going to win
do you think you're going to win despite
that rosalind you still enjoyed doing
the thing that's what i'm interested in
i i i enjoyed it but a lot of times i
would do it just to show her is that you
don't think
[Music]
did that extend to acting then
no not as much acting because to her not
as much acting because i left puerto
rico when i was 21. i did a tv show for
three years i started as a dancer then i
became um part of the comedy sketches it
was like a living color but the puerto
rican version of the living color it was
the number one live show i started as a
fly girl and then i moved my way off
um
wasn't it
i started dancing then i will and then
literally by the third year i started um
doing
um some of the comedy sketches then i
won this pageant and then that's when i
decided i want to move to new york cause
i want to do musical theater that was my
dream
um and my parents
wanted me to finish college i left
three years into it i had one more year
for my bachelor's degree but i knew what
i wanted to do so i left so it was
difficult for them for my
dad was very important yeah it was
important for my dad to bring that
degree that
bachelor's degree my mom he's not wrong
oh i know he was he was not he was not
he was not uh but my mom because she
wanted me to be a performer my mom was a
little bit more forgiving but it wasn't
the thing with acting was that she
wasn't as
strong with the acting thing and maybe
he had to do because i by the time i
started doing it seriously i left the
island so she wasn't with me all the
time okay to give me you never heard of
love
which is probably the best thing for you
and in terms of like
you're just emotional mentally yeah yes
yes yes so how soon into your acting
career did your father
let go of that um
you know whatever issues he had with you
not finishing school i mean was yeah i
mean how successful did you have to
become until he was like okay i get it
uh and and i i'm letting this go the
premiere of rush hour two
that was my first big movie that
premiere was massive they closed
hollywood boulevard it was absolutely
massive i remember that i flew my whole
family my brothers my parents i was
doing the the line the the red carpet
you know my family was kind of like
looking in the distance and i remember
seeing my face he had a suit my dad's
face he had a suit on and he kept
looking at me and i it was he was just
like beaming it was the first time that
that i think he went she's going to be
okay he's going to be yeah yeah that's
great yeah and that's all it is it's not
it's funny like with parents it's not um
and i would imagine i'd be the same way
it's not it's not
oh they're gonna they're they're in a
movie they're in
you know they're on a red carpet all
that [ __ ] all the trappings yeah
it's that it's what you said there's a
beauty in there they're gonna be okay
yes
yes and i know i don't know it was
beautiful it was beautiful and before i
remember before that i was in new york i
was already like it's been like a year
since i was in new york now eight months
i think it was and i was taking my
singing classes and and like i was going
to hb studios and i was starting and i
i left and i i went to the my parents
said the only way you're leaving is you
have to go to my
my mom's second cousin in the bronx
castle hill uh her name is i didn't
really know about kuka because i didn't
know about cuca right nobody talked
about bakuga and then i moved i'm
surprised if i knew akuka i would
mention her all the time it's a great
name
and the family
because i thought it was going to happen
overnight justin because i was doing the
number one live comedy show in puerto
rico i was a beauty queen i was doing so
well in puerto rico i thought moving to
new york it's just going to be a matter
of a month until i become summer hyke at
the time it wasn't even in jail at the
time the the it goes on right so i
thought it was going to be granted my
english was all it's still bad but my
english was horrible and and it's not oh
my god so it's been a struggle anyways
so
i thought it was going to be more it was
going to move much faster and then i it
took it took a couple of months for me
to realize reality check
this is not going to be as as easy as i
thought you know nobody cares i'm going
to be with kuka a little longer i'm
going to be with cook a little longer
absolutely
i don't know i was like frustrated
my singing coach said to me why don't
you just come up with like a little
one-woman show we go to the village we
rent this little space space called the
duplex i'll get you a piano player uh
yeah three new seasons you know the
duplex the two places remember i was at
the second floor i was like they faced
like 75 people and i did my whole thing
called out here on my own that was the
name of the thing
i wrote five monologues and i had a song
after each monologue about my experience
since i moved to
since i left puerto rico and moved to
new york
and the struggle of taking a subway even
though it was claustrophobic and how
difficult it was like i would take the
numbers that i would walk to the bus
station and then grab the bus to the to
the subway and then take the six all the
way to manhattan and then dress like a
little boy because they don't want to be
bothered and then going to a mcdonald's
in manhattan and changing and putting
makeup to go to auditions and then oh
wow go to acting so you would sing songs
about those things i was singing songs
and then talking about that experience
that i never told my parents because the
second i said to my dad i never took
public transportation in puerto rico my
life so if i would have said to my
parents i am taking a dollar cab when i
don't want to take the bus and then um
my father would have said you're coming
back now like immediately right
would that be what now now just to
dissect that
psychologically with or attempt to would
that have been a pride issue was it more
about safety was it um was it a sign
that you weren't thriving in a way that
they you would have been in puerto rico
everything i think a combination of
everything plus but i think a lot of it
is as a dad the safety issue you know i
mean like i was yeah yeah i was i was i
was a little girl i was the only girl i
was the youngest one you know but like i
had i
i had everything i needed like why in
the world are you struggling
when we gave you everything you know
so that makes sense it was really
interesting and they came my parents
came to see the show because i presented
it as i'm doing a one-woman show when i
have musicians you know one day they
show up and it's this lighted tiny
little venue
but i was in heaven i was doing what i
loved you know so i did it and how
halfway through the show
i see my dad because he's only 75 people
i see my dad getting up i'm leaving
oh wow i'm but i'm on stage and i'm
doing my thing and i see the whole thing
and i was like oh [ __ ]
okay so but i kept going so at the end
of the whole thing he's out he's at the
bar he's drinking and i said dad oh my
god you you luck
huh and he said to me you never said he
was tears he says he never said any of
this and i said because i couldn't
because you were gonna tell me that i
had to go back home and i'm fine dad i'm
fine i promise you i promise you what
they didn't know is what i did that two
weeks before the show happened
i booked my first american gig which
which was as the world turns a soap
opera for cbs for sure and i signed a
three-year contract so even though i did
the show about struggling at the end of
the show
my announcement was and guess what guys
i am gonna be yourself and to me that
was huge i'm doing an american stuff and
i can barely i can barely speak english
and here i am doing a soap you know well
i love that you were able to communicate
to him uh in that in that way in a way
that you loved and probably very
honestly yeah i did and he was he was
fine it was it was a shock you know but
then we spent a whole week together and
then they went back home and then what
was it three years later i get rush hour
i get rocha with you wow and and from
that review i should point out that uh
the hit single kuka is driving me cuckoo
uh was released from
they must have been so excited about as
the world turns because i know it is in
puerto rico our telem telenovelas as
popular as they are in the rest of latin
america uh
yeah but not north american telenovelas
in puerto rico um
it's the novellas from colombia from
venezuela from brazil the third the
turkey turkish zobra is a huge at the
moment so i don't think puerto ricans
know about it wasn't about as well turns
and and and guiding light and general
hospital in puerto rico they'd like to
see content from latin america i see but
it was just stability i mean your dad
sees you having a regular job i mean
that must have done yeah
um rosalind i heard that jackie chan is
an incredibly like an insanely hard
worker like yes crazy work ethic
um was that your experience with him 200
000 you know jackie has
his team he's like an entourage yeah he
has his team
that they're the kids that do all the
stunt work and the choreographer
everything and it's like military
entourage yes but they're all they're
all incredibly disciplined and quiet and
it's almost like they are there to do a
job they don't look at anybody
it's it's military it's a military
approach precise yeah he's so precise
he's lovely jackie is lovely and he's
funny
but when they he enters on set with his
group it's all that wow wow yeah it was
interesting um
and and so do you prefer the stability
of because i know you've done so many
successful shows you've done without a
trace then devious maids
both of which probably have very loyal
following um so i imagine you get a lot
of
attention from people who probably feel
like they know you it's it's a
difference between doing i believe maybe
things have changed because now these
movie stars and everybody doing movies
all they want to do is streaming you
know because there's amazing content
nowadays even on network tv um so before
like if you were just doing movies
you're unapproachable you know you're at
the airport and people oh they want to
talk to you but they they
approach you know when you do a tv show
it's like they're with you and you're in
their living room they see you every
single day they feel like they're part
of your family so you get you get both
you know you get people that they feel
like they know you and i have people
that come to me and say can i hug you
said oh my god of course you know and
then you have people that they maybe not
now
yeah you know they look they look at you
and they they're so afraid to say
anything it's a it's a little bit of
everything
i bet well especially i've never had the
experience of playing a character that
people some people don't like like i
remember i mean i mean on a tv show but
i've had i've had friends who have
played which i'd love to who have played
like kind of more
you know spicier like villainous parts
and um
and
but i've only i i once had a woman come
up to me on a beach and she started
kicking sand on me and she said um
you're an idiot like berating me you're
right you're what an idiot and i said
well what's going on she goes would you
just ask her out already
and i said well and there was a girl in
my life at the time that i was like i
couldn't muster the courage to ask out
and i was like oh you must know
so so and so she goes what no
and she said a character on this tv show
that i was doing
like a nerdy
yeah unbelievable and my character
couldn't ask her out and she was i said
oh the show yeah whatever the writers
write you know and she and she didn't
really accept that she was like yeah no
just ask her out
interesting
interesting yeah so i imagine people on
those i mean you must get you know uh
people get invested and i'm sure eric
knows about that from the rookie because
that's another one of those shows where
people are really invested people are
really really invested with this
character 100
100 you know it's it i did them over
years ago called boat trip and the movie
it became a more of like a cult classic
you know like
i mean i feel bad for cuba good ratio
yes correct with the racial science yes
and i have a scene with a absolutely not
seen with a
with a banana that is kind of like a
graphic scene but it's very funny you
know it's very funny and i was so young
and to me that it was such a i don't
know if i would have done it now
but at the time i was young
it was such a huge opportunity for me
because i mean he just won the oscar i
know right
snl and roger moore was like a legend
you know what i mean so we thought he
was gonna yeah he won
yeah it was like we thought it was gonna
be the biggest thing ever no no snow
dogs what oh no no huh well with uh
jerry maguire
he yes
she was yeah
huge so you know when you do a movie
thinking the people around me are
incredible so this movie's gonna be
great anyways doesn't really matter i
did the same with the banana to this day
and that was more than 20 years ago
probably on social media i get tweets
about that moment and that day and
people talk about it and men love it and
they're so affected by it you know what
i'm going this is really crazy how
little moments like that
caught on camera for film or tv people
define you
isn't that amazing i know
i know we have a limited time uh ruslan
so i'm i'm going to try to rifle through
this but i do want to talk about fantasy
island um because well first of all the
thing that struck me was
how lucky you are to get to shoot
at a location where do you guys shoot
that show in puerto rico where i'm from
in puerto rico my god okay so you get to
be
back with your relatives do you get to
see your relatives and stuff you're
shooting so my family my parents are
there two of my brothers live there and
and my parents that's awesome most of my
family and then to tell you what a great
job do you want to hear something
incredible so i this is my fourth
production in puerto rico i believe but
granite because i would i did tv
19 20 21 years old and then i was a
beauty queen and then i won
internationally so people knew
people in puerto rico have known my my
journey my dream of like i left the
island because i wanted to move to
america you know to be able to be a
performer so they've seen that here you
are you know they've seen the whole
journey they're one of the
cameraographers which is a fabulous
steadicam operator um edgar colon used
to be the cameragrapher for my little tv
show at the time when i was 19 years old
and now i'm living color one
uh yes
and now here we are 25 years later
almost 20 yeah 23. and he's the camera
guy this is that's how long we've known
each other most of the crew i've known
i've worked with before a lot of the
actors i directed a short film in puerto
rico half of my crew is the crew of
fantasy island it was such a it's been
such an incredible moment for me to be
able to go to that oh wow with a show
that is an incredible intellectual
properly uh property you know it this
ips i love it all over the world and to
be able to have the lead girl be puerto
rican that they know so well for
uh english network tv it was it was it's
been such a big deal
for the for the economy for the tourism
in puerto rico we are so we're so happy
so we're hoping that we get a second
third fourth season so we can continue
um helping them this way you know it's
i'm sure it's also a really fun show
it's it's um i didn't know see i had
never seen the original so this was my
introduction to it the idea that like
people come to this island and they're
they their fantasies are fulfilled and
and it's got this like supernatural
element i i didn't realize that um
were you a fan of the original and and
um
tell tell me how it differs from the
original and and does it yeah it was a
70s so i was young i was young but i do
remember we had it in spanish we had
dubbed in spanish and and to me the the
phrase i love you they're playing the
plane i remember really well i remember
the tattoo character really well i
remember that regardless you remember
that because
it was and is such a beloved um icon for
latinos you know so i know the premise
of course i i remember seeing some
episodes as a little girl i wasn't very
clear i got i gathered the offer i went
back i went to youtube and i started
watching some episodes so i can refresh
you know
my memory um the the
the concept is very is very similar it's
uh the premise is the same it's about
like you say people go to the island
they go in uh trying to fulfill the
fantasy and of course uh what they want
is not what they actually need the
island is ever present the island is
like god so the island knows exactly
what you need to be able to make you a
better person you go through this
journey of pain sometimes laughter
sometimes tears sometimes whatever it is
to actually
get what you deserve and what you need
you leave the island you're a better
human being that's the premise of the
original and the no one yeah because i
remember in the pilot for example
there's a woman who just wants to be
able to eat whatever she wants she had a
like dan harris whom we were speaking
about she has a
panic attack on a t tv she's a news
anchor yes bellamy
young places yes um
who by the way is very bright i saw her
on jeopardy once she was on celebrity
jeopardy i thought she won it uh she did
she's bright and she's talented she's a
great actress yeah
yeah she's good in the show um so she
wants to for example just to give people
a little insight she wants to eat what
she wants to be able to eat whatever she
wants and uh and and and then still look
the same when she leaves the island um
things like that or people want to
reconnect they want to find love again
they want to they want their their youth
again uh it's a really great premise uh
rosalind what would your i'm sure you've
been asked this and forgive me if this
is a cliche fantasy island related
question but what would your fantasy be
if you were to go to an island like that
what would you want
oh my god sorry josie my phone just fell
over she was so
wait sorry uh so sick of hearing that
question that she threw
yeah
because because
i don't sleep enough because i have two
kids i might like i need to meditate
like you hey because my mind is crazy i
want to go to an island i just bring a
book and just sleep that's what i want
rosalind rosalind in in my world that is
a fantasy that's a great fantasy i don't
know what that says about me and how
exciting i a life i live but uh that's
that's that's like i need to sleep
without without taking a sleeping pill i
don't know what i want to know yeah that
sounded bad but i want to be able to
just no i want to sleep
honestly relax true relaxation
that's a great answer life could be a
dream
[Music]
hey life assured listeners business wars
is a podcast from wondering that brings
you the full stories behind some of the
biggest business battles in history in
their new season you'll hear about the
fight between espn vs fox sports to
dominate the sports television industry
espn is the american cable network that
plays the trail for around the clock
sports coverage athletes even change the
way they play just to get on
sportscenter's nightly highlight reels
but right around the corner rupert
murdoch's fox sports channel started
gaining on espn in the us the sports tv
business is worth more than 12 billion
dollars the question is who will come
out on top fox sports or espn listen to
business wars espn vs fox sports on
apple podcast amazon music or you can
listen one week early and add free by
joining wondering plus in the wundry app
hey life is short listeners i want you
to imagine that you're on a warship in
the final days of world war ii you're
excited to go back home looks like the
war's ending you've just delivered the
necessary parts for the atom bomb
but then
disaster strikes your ship is struck by
enemy torpedoes and within minutes
you're floating in the ocean fighting
for survival from wandery against the
odds is an immersive podcast that puts
you in the shoes of resilient people
surviving harrowing ordeals in their new
season you'll hear about the infamous
sinking of uss indianapolis and the
survivors fight to stay alive it's a
fascinating story you probably know the
story of the uss indianapolis from the
famous scene in jaws that robert shaw
recounts
it is harrowing to say the least the
sailors who survived the attack were
stranded in the open ocean for
uh five days i believe they endured
brutal weather
rough seas dehydration salt water
poisoning hallucinations and it was one
of the deadliest shark attacks in
history
against the odds has the harrowing true
story of how the brave men of the
indianapolis survived the worst disaster
at sea in u.s naval history listen to
against the odds on apple podcasts
amazon music or you can listen a week
early and add free by joining wunderplus
in the wondery app
hello hello again
we'll meet again
[Music]
i really want to talk about this too
before we get to the lightning round and
um
fundacion de nino
george san george
yes got a year and a half of spanish and
that's what i do with that it's okay
that is so embarrassing it's fine um but
it it sounds incredible they assist uh
sick children from poor families and is
it in a specific region is it just in
puerto rico uh well that one
specifically fundacion jorge is in
puerto rico i was a godmother for many
many years i produced events
specifically for triathlons in puerto
rico to raise money for their foundation
um it's they deal with mainly kids with
cancer or lupus you know or like immune
or immune diseases the work that they do
is it's just stunning you know and i
remember i started working with them
before i was a
a mom
so you can only imagine when you do work
um with children sick children
and you have children of your own it
takes a whole new meaning you know it's
it's it's been
it's been an incredible learning
experience and and and to realize um
what these families go through i
remember i remember the first triathlon
was dedicated to uh jaded that was the
uh
derek was a
the the patient that i
i don't know if you believe that
sometimes there's a soul connection
between
you meet somebody and there's a soul
connection either you i don't know if
you believe in this like
you you knew the person from other lives
i now believe in that uh wholeheartedly
and it was really intense the connection
that i had this with this little kid he
was maybe six years old ended up at
saint jude's no yes induced hospital in
tennessee
um and i remember that
i flew to tennessee because i wanted to
see him and visit him to see how he was
doing with the cancer treatment um and
the whole the whole
first triathlon was dedicated to him we
arranged for him to travel to puerto
rico just for the triathlon because my
dream was to be able to cross the finish
line with him
oh man that's amazing i was in puerto
rico a week before the triathlon still
organizing producing the whole thing i
get the dreadful uh text from my driver
in puerto rico saying
rest in peace um derek i passed out i
was like what do you mean he's scheduled
to come
in a couple of days
he didn't make it so can you imagine me
producing this event doing a triathlon
that i've never done before which is
extremely difficult already you know the
discipline of running um swimming and
biking i was so i was so intimidated but
i wanted to do it so badly because i'm
going this is nothing compared to what
these kids go through when they do chemo
and and fighting for their lives or else
you can do this this is nothing this is
nothing and he didn't make it but he
family was there with me and it it
that foundation and the work that you do
if you're blessed enough to work with
children is life-changing it's not
changing yeah yeah i would love uh to
exchange
any kind of efforts any anything i can
be of value
for to to promote um to be a part of it
i
it sounds really um life-changing oh my
gosh thank you
in nicaragua a group called the girls
home madre albertina is home for girls
and i'm sure they would
lo i i we can exchange information about
our two
groups because it sounds uh similarly um
inclined
justin i went to nicaragua and i saw you
i saw a picture that you posted uh with
the girls and i thought for a second
when i read nicaragua i was like oh my
god he's with operation smile that other
organization that kids with their left
palate
i realized oh it's a different
foundation he's dealing with kids it's a
different deal but i went to nicaragua
with operation smile and that was also a
surreal
experience for me
it was beautiful yeah
oh i bet i i i love seeing kids uh
excited by
figures such as yourself down there
because
i remember going i work with a group
called this is about humanity to uh
they do a lot of work at the border in a
lot of the refugee camps at the border
you know as you know mostly central
americans salvadorans hondurans but um
to see so we go down there and there
there are a bunch of actors who come and
nobody really knows them down there you
know and we went with an actress uh asa
gonzalez friend of the show uh
and and asa
it really like
brought me so much joy to see the kids
and the families excited by her i must
be you must have similar experiences
it's so cool to to see that you know so
i know
your presence must mean a lot to those
kids and families and it's really cool
that you spend your time that way i love
it it's it's uh it's not about you you
know this business is so about me me me
me and when you're able to use your
platform to help other people that's
what it's all about you know i i i enjoy
it i enjoy it immensely i think it's a
beautiful thing to do good on you and um
and back to you uh uh this is this
that's a pivot that i made at the record
show
fantasy island we'll talk about it but
it airs tuesdays 9 8 8 central on fox uh
we just have a quick lightning round uh
okay
what is your most commonly used emoji
these are hard hitting questions uh this
one is that an emoji
hands yeah yeah sure or the pink heart
the pink heart the double pink or the
just the
single paint okay uh if you could be a
professional athlete what sport would
you play figure skating figure skating
oh wow okay that has ballet elements to
a dance dance around to me is the
ultimate sport to me figure skating is
everything oh man did you fee do you
skate in puerto rico no because we in
puerto rico's on island the caribbean is
super hot we don't have ice rinks so the
the the fact that i wasn't able to do it
my entire life that's kind of what
that's what i wanted to be figure
skating well that's what i that's what i
would have figured rosalind so that's
probably sounded like a really dumb
follow-up question but uh if you could
have one snack food for the rest of your
life what would it be uh cheetos oh
delicious great great answer uh
out of curiosity the one thing i hate
about it what do you do with the dust on
your face
and then clean your wipes
it's a nightmare but i love cheetos
what's your go-to karaoke song uh
faithfully from journey okay great song
who was your first celebrity crush ralph
ralph marshall oh wow friend of the show
former guest at the show if you had to
get a tattoo uh what would you get and
where um
i don't have any tattoos i'll probably
do my kid's name sabella and dylan and
i'll probably do it
maybe
over here oh and your neck
the back of my head yeah but like very
like very same like like
cursives okay like the characters yeah
yeah like that like very pretty very
very dainty very like that oh cool
beautiful um yeah uh
what's your favorite fruit you from an
island that has you know so much
delicious fruit my favorite fruit is
guajaba which is guava guava we've never
had that answer guava good i'm i'm so
unfamiliar with guava because we so
rarely get ripe guavas here oh guava
guava is the best the best thing in the
world yeah oh wow what what's your
what's your go-to pizza topping pizza i
don't know if pizza but if i could have
anything probably
mushrooms i don't know i don't do a lot
of pizza mushrooms okay well that makes
sense uh would you say the beetles are
the rolling stones do you prefer beetles
okay did you have a favorite song a song
that you would love to hear right now
from the beatles yeah
i feel surprised
no not at all listen to me i grew up in
puerto rico these don't work for uh for
everyone
like a noodle like a little size
type of girl
okay
okay
well that's it um that makes sense that
makes perfect sense these are very
limited uh this is from a limited field
these questions are coming from um you
have been so kind and i'm i'm sorry to
take it i've totally taken advantage of
your time your kindness um
this has been so enjoyable though thank
you so much thank you for having me i
appreciate it oh it was a pleasure it
was fun and tell eric i say hi a hundred
percent okay good to see you okay
bye-bye
[Music]
[Laughter]
so that just happened that just happened
i don't know if you can do that well i'm
doing it as i'm really i remember
speculating we talked about this do you
remember when yes don't tell me um it
was another guest wilmer yes yes
yeah but i thought that that felt more
okay because you were friends with him
and he said it was okay exactly he
laughed at it so he's right and it's
very specifically warmer the truth is i
don't think i could do i shouldn't
attempt a rosalind sanchez impression a
because it's potentially offensive or is
that b i was going to say a might be
because i just can't do a good one oh i
would lean more towards b
i i don't know if you're allowed to do
stuff like that but maybe not maybe
we're being too you know what it is
there might be two two cents maybe we're
being too sensitive see i think we're so
i just don't want to offend anybody i
know but here's the thing you're going
and you've said this to me before you're
going to offend somebody this is what i
will say about rosalind sanchez yeah
obviously i can't say for sure but
having heard her for the last hour
she seems like someone who would be
totally cool with you doing an
impression of her accent right but she
seems very cool to the point where
they're fun and like very easygoing very
very easy to talk to yeah and very cool
stuff like that uh to the point where
like i actually wasn't thinking about
rosalind i was thinking about like
people listening rosalind sanchez though
easy going and now he's offended yeah
very very cool so cool and and you know
you guys had a nice rapport yeah yeah
and you knew her husband yes isn't that
funny eric i he was so handsome i
remember like um that scene was tough
for me because i had to do some
i think i got to kind of mention this in
our talk but like i i had to do
something that was inherently shitty in
the scene
and so they really needed him to push it
they needed it to be like so it wasn't
as obvious that what i was doing was
shitty i turn around and i'm just like
try to steal this guy's girlfriend he is
good in that i remember him in that
that's a good movie it was funny that
she hadn't seen it that's a really good
movie and he and her husband is is funny
in it and it's and she didn't see it and
it was funny when she was like who's in
that and i you had i could tell you at a
moment where you want to be like well me
because it that movie if you've seen
that movie i didn't say me comet no
because you didn't wanted to sound
arrogant she's like well who's in the
movie and you were like um
yeah emmy rossum's also in it
but like she definitely didn't see it
you know because if she had students
she would know that i know she wasn't
funny that's crazy
like she's like i love the rookie but
i've never seen it i i didn't want to
shame her and we shouldn't now because
the truth is i don't think it's that
weird if you um our best my best friend
togo again uh
supporter of the supporter of the show
big support he was on csi miami for
years and the first season he was on i
remember watching the first couple
episodes he did you know to be a
supportive friend and and at a certain
point it's like it's on every week
he's doing a good job but like i see
what he's doing on it didn't he get a
little earthquake
you didn't watch the show though he did
and and his and you weren't married to
him that's right so
in eric winter's defense i would kind of
understand why he'd be like i never
thought i'd say you say that
i mean it's on every week i've got a big
part maybe see a scene or two yeah
i'm in the cold open just watch that
this week he might not watch fantasy
island that's true do you think he
they also have kids like they have their
hands full that's what i meant when it
was like when i when i said i because i
meant that i don't think it's that big
of a deal like i i don't know if i'd be
offended by that i've dated girls who
don't see movies i'm in and stuff and
like i'm not offended i'm not like if
anything it's like kind of weird
sometimes to be like
well
not this is a strange comparison because
we're not married but
i feel bad that i've been engaged no i
mean to you
[Laughter]
to different people i haven't um i
haven't seen certain thanks for
clarifying that by the way i haven't
seen certain things you've done and i
feel
like you do
yeah oh no i'm curious what no because i
you've seen the things that i you know
i'm like proud not all of them oh really
no
i've never i'm not proud of that many
i've never seen the wave oh i am proud
of that uh i've never seen you see the
waves i've never seen most of jiri [ __ ]
oh that's a cool series
proud of that
okay what else are you proud of yeah
cheerihaji but like
yeah you could you you would like that
just as a filmmaker you would like that
it's the way it's done i mean i've only
seen tusk once and i don't think i'd
watch it again right you don't need to
say that again fantasy island's fun on
fox we should have yeah are they paying
you um
um it's it's a really good show and i
was never how much i never watched the
original one i hadn't either and you
both have to not have seen the original
fantasy the
what would you guess my only association
is with fans
specifically they're playing the plane
more specifically the plane the plane
not more insultingly
more specific than that your eyes just
[ __ ] out here
i mean like what from what specifically
uh fantasy island um him saying that you
know
in a commercial
and um okay wait wait don't tell me
you'll get it the plane the plane
yes yes that is my fantasy island
association until now until roslyn says
yeah mine too i guess you don't both
have to have the same association
and i you know i to the point where i
didn't know that fantasy island was
about that like you go to this island
and just tell them your fantasy and they
make it happen that's cool neither it's
a great idea how do you do it now within
with a new audience i should have asked
her but i can't i don't want to ask
people you know it's i think you i know
doesn't it seem a little too like risky
it does it does what island would be a
fantasy of your like iceland or japan or
uh i mean if you could pick any island
to live in well japan i love japan i
want to retire in japan
i want to die in japan yeah i know we've
been talking about this yeah
i don't want to retire you want to die
soon in japan no no i don't want to die
soon um
japan nor do i want to retire maybe ever
yeah because i don't really consider
myself having a job per se but um that's
another well i mean in a way in a sense
that like nine to five i'm itching to
like yeah i gotta hang out stop working
so i don't have a boss and i wanna like
just go play golf all the time i don't
have that kind of job but i do wanna die
in japan i think yeah
i respect that rosalind sanchez treated
the lightning round
as a lightning round she did
um we were also running out of time okay
but a little little to take that away
from a little bone to pick with you oh
good i like little bones if you don't
mind no no as long as it's a little bone
like a little fish bone it's a little
bone um
uh you've gone to the habit lately of
when you asked the beatles and the
rolling stones question
of asking what song they want to hear
right now yeah and occasionally
you'll get an answer that's you know
someone will have be excited to answer
that question but nine times out of ten
i've noticed that
it's a struggle for people because when
you say
what do you want to hear right now
you're in a bar you're in a jukebox
you're not in a bar exactly it's like
you're talking to me right now so you're
forcing someone right to imagine that
they're not talking to you
imagine themselves in a bar and there's
like what and it's also like what
beetles are like ah there's a [ __ ]
million beetles songs i was like all
right
song beetles are great you could have
said this to me off uh it's been it's
been um
not plaguing me but it's been like
festering a little bit yeah it was like
it's not a big deal it was a little bone
that's turned into a medium bone well it
sounds like a medium i think it's turned
into a medium bone because you did it
with her and she's like from puerto rico
and was like i don't know i like menudo
i don't like know about it
if you ask me like the beatles are my
favorite band yeah but if you ask me
what and i'm having like a conversation
with you yeah and you say what beatle
song do you want to hear in a bar right
remove yourself i'd be like i'd be like
okay and i'm barbie and then my next
thought would be like oh my god there's
a thousand beetle songs that i love i
don't have i mean i do have a favorite
beale song but like you know he knows
people don't you know what though
because i i've been exa i just just been
examining this i wonder if we should cut
the the question only because i'd be
okay with that yeah because you know you
know why i think i do that follow-up is
because i it always feels like um
not the best quite like to like who
cares rolling stones repeats the problem
is we have a few interviews in the bank
so as we're having this conversation i
realized oh yeah the next all right well
then the next few episodes we'll still
have that but then we'll favorite maybe
in the new year
that's a good point is that a good plan
yeah so you know we should change up all
those questions not all of them so we
should um replace some of them and add
some of them in the new year that's what
yeah we should do that there are a
couple that people are 20 22 baby oh
we're curious we have some killer
questions yeah uh i'm going to stop
talking about like sexualizing fruit um
i'm just stopping the michael's
right
guava sounds good yeah it does um let's
read a letter okay
all right this is from katie henkel how
do you spell her last name uh hen like a
hen
cal like a kell k-e-l heckle
what'd you think i thought it might be
kle or i don't know i was curious
subject praise dad energy and would you
rather okay hi justin and christian i
just want to say that i absolutely love
the podcast and i find it really helpful
for my self-care oh how nice thank you
katie
oh whoa i am a therapist who works as a
first responder wow
i.e i work alongside police which is
rewarding but can also be very stressful
overwhelming and emotionally draining
some days i bet your podcast is so light
uplifting entertaining and just a joy to
listen to which is just what i need
after a tough day that's so nice so
thank you for helping me get through the
rough times and making me smile and
laugh when i need it the most that's
very nice thank you katie um yeah how
nice um i also want to say to justin i
really hope you become a dad someday
that's what a nice compliment i hope you
become a father you mentioned like
that's like one of the nicest things you
can think about somebody
um
christian i think you'd be a good step
father shut up right here um and she
says uh back to the letter you're goofy
you're
goofy all right
you're goofy kind open-minded accepting
don't take yourself too seriously etc
and i think any kid would be lucky to
have you as a dad what a nice and you
could afford a team of nannies
yeah i was about to say uh
this uh one of our mother wrote this is
that that's our mother's pseudonym is
katie henkel but you know what sadly i
don't think our mother would say this
about i don't think so either that those
would be good attributes i think our
mother would think you'd be a good
father but i don't think she would say
those things no i don't think she would
lead with goofy kind open-minded
accepting don't those are all such
things i really value so that's so nice
that's a nice compliment oh god it
really is um
and just to reassure you it back to
katie and just to reassure you it's not
too late my dad was 46 when i was born
huh oh yeah you'd be an old dad and um
his age has never been an issue ah
that's really good here isn't that crazy
it would be an old dad yeah that's wild
you'd be an old dad oh man that's all
right well i want to be able to run
around but you're a youthful 43 year old
you know what i mean like
you're you're you know but you're useful
for your age we're just talking about
how things are really like slowing down
and stuff how tired i get i've
been going to bed at like 10
uh anyway but her dad katie's dad 46
that's good to hear it's really
encouraging back to katie it's actually
helped me not care about age at all
because he's never seemed old to me
which i find to be a blessing wow this
is such a great letter
it makes me want to like just keep
reading letters it's so nice
okay and would you rather time yes
thank you katie would you rather have a
would you rather this is great would you
rather have a menstrual cycle just like
any person with a uterus
i.e it lasts about a week you experience
the full array of symptoms but it stops
at middle age
or get
or
get kicked in the nuts twice a day every
day for the rest of your life
but you never get used to it and it
hurts just as much each time oh my well
katie you clearly don't have nuts no
no wait how did how does she describe
getting kicked in the nuts you know she
doesn't say how hard i don't care
it makes a difference definitely a and i
know i've obviously never had
uh a period
but
i have been around that was a funny
place to put a period but i've been
around enough people who have had
varying degrees of a period you know i
can't wait to hear this well
varying like severity of a period um
some you know easier some harder some
like have a lot more pain than others
however
um
even like the worst version of it that
i've like been around
uh twice a day that seems no much
preferable much more much more
preferable than getting kicked in the
next
this is the inherent problem this is the
pair but i don't know because i've never
had exactly she and she doesn't have
katie doesn't have nuts no frame of
reference exactly maybe
i will say though here's the difference
if we can be objective the most
objective we can be
i've seen people get hit in the nuts
and i've seen people have periods
exactly so and i've seen what they look
like i've seen how they respond i've
seen that i've seen what their faces
look like it's a different much
different
okay what if just to specify it a little
bit more because it but it's hard for us
to answer because we've also been
experiencing it's impossible impossible
but that's the that's the trouble with
this question but i suspect getting hit
in the nuts is significantly more
painful and then that's it's hit in the
nuts is one thing like you could be hit
with a
guava it's significantly more painful
but i will say having your period
there's all these other things you have
to deal with you'd have to
i know as a man
let's say it happens that if you're out
of your penis yeah i thought about this
then you would have to have some sort of
stop up your yeah you'd have some sort
of diaper or something for a week
every month i know until you're middle
age which is like you know i'm almost
there so in this scenario i'd almost be
i'd be like a decade away from menopause
so i would definitely pick that option
another reason to pick that option but
if i'm like 75 years old getting kicked
in the nuts twice a day oh man get out
of here and
i i think even at once twice a month
would be really hard because you'd also
be thinking about that date approaching
that's the time
that's a better question that's the
that's a harder question for me to
answer i sort of thought she was like
like once a month a period every month
for the rest of your life yeah or and no
menopause or
uh getting kicked really hard in the in
the mo in the nuts once a month for the
rest of your life you almost said in the
mouth i still think i might
pick the period it's an inherently
impossible question to answer
we don't know what that's like and nor
does a woman know what it's like to get
kicked in the nuts it's just a woman
would know what it's like to get
potentially she would know what it's
like to get hit by something in the
genitals i've one gender i mean that
i think is very painful for women it
must be but but
i think the
i don't know are you mansplaining yeah
just about demands my gender vaginal
pain yeah because but like we don't know
yeah you're right we don't know if it
was like if katie had specified like
kicked in the nuts twice a day by a
three-year-old maybe i would take that
because a three-year-old i've been
kicked in the nuts by three-year-olds
you have
what did you do to that volunteer
um
you know when you're playing with yeah
yeah that's different but if i kicked
you in the nuts with like uh wearing a
hiking boot forget it i'd be throwing i
mean it'd be them it'd be like i'd be
doubled over in pain you'd rather have a
period all the time yeah i i don't
i think it would be similar mm-hmm i
don't know see we can't even we can't
talk about periods no no no we can't
we're talking about periods way too much
well katie asked us i know no i know
it's not our fault um anyway back to
katie that's all i got best wishes katie
what a great letter man
that's one of those letters that like it
makes me really happy we do this segment
of the show you know i mean all the
letters i like there's never been a
letter where i'm like oh man that made
me feel really bad you know i would like
yeah i agree fun to read that's true i
would like i think it'd be fun to do a
show just of reading letters and talking
about them it's a great way to get to
know maybe we should do more letters on
the show i enjoy it maybe in the new
year so thank you katie and thank you to
rosalind sanchez and everyone yeah go
watch fantasy island on fox and if you
want to write into the show our email
address is life is short wondering.com
talk to you next week okay bye
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
life is short is hosted by me
justin long it's co-hosted and produced
by you christian long it's also produced
by megan v monaco and katie p allen
senior producer is michelle miesh lans
and audio engineer is sergio enriquez he
works with a man whose title is
executive producer that man's name is
marshall louis for a company that
employs all types of people it's called
wandery
[Music]
no but even now like i've noticed my leg
hair is has stopped growing as much as
it used to like my body hair is slowing
down you used to have a lot of forearm
hair me i still do it's weird did you
know that that he has a lot of hair but
it's light so you don't really notice it
oh he has thick hair he's like robin
williams on the
forearms but i have light colored hair
so it doesn't stand out so much yes i
know
you know i used to have like two of
these crazy hairs coming out of a little
mole on my arm
whoa
not the reaction i expected what a
reaction do you expect oh cool no and
then you had mole hairs no but like that
looked like this hair now and then one
day it was just like
yeah my whole arm looked like that
you think that's from the mall no
you know what would be the hardest part
for me
i'm sure i'll get back here one day too
yeah i mean you might not i'm so grossed
out by me you might not think you will
get it probably i think if we've avoided
it this long i don't have back hair you
you're pretty new you have back hair
oh yeah
whenever i was shaving it the other day
when i was doing this
you think oh
oh that's different than like
i don't have like a pellet
you